at the end of the day bro being black is
is a great thing man that's what I
wanted to come on to this podcast and
talk about thanks man yeah you think I
could do it do it Be Blood yeah in the
future
do I have what it takes or not
[__] no
but I'll tell you what man come on bro
you've done some great things in life
but [__] no but look man you know you've
got you got hope man you ever dated a
black girl
I went home with one black girl one time
well how'd that go
this biker was wild she had like a uh I
like how you said this yeah well
she was it go ahead explain the story
how we go again I want to hear the story
though I want to hear the story she had
a kind of a mirror on her ceiling but it
wasn't like it was on like one of those
mirrors they have at like a bus stop
where it's like reflective metal yeah
yeah the [__] it like pans around yeah
so she had that [__] on the ceiling
dude and I was re I was [__] nervous
bruh the one that like the like the
American twist around and you could if
you're looking right here you can see it
around the other one yeah a little bit
on the yeah yeah it feels like an oval
yeah she had that thing up on the
ceiling man and I and uh in the corner
of the room she had like one of those
coat of arms like you would see from
like the night times or whatever you
know I think she was like one of those
Renaissance Fair sisters you know and uh
and she [__] had yeah they had like
axes on the one I mean that [__] she
was white you know so she was like as
white as you could get
a black girl bro I swears
so I was ready you know I was [__]
fired up and I remember [__] doing
like this right when I got over there
and
um I was excited but I would date a
black girl man I think uh I definitely
feel more open to it when I was young I
think black girls were a lot more
intimidating because they seemed a lot
more
like confidence
are they yes black women are very
confident and they know they know what
they want they straight up with you like
don't bring that little dick over here
oh damn they want that big ass dick big
dick they want you to throw that dick
over your shoulder like a belt
yeah
like a dead fox [__] rope man like
you know like but that can be
intimidating which I get I understand it
yeah I always envied about black people
is that they have like the best origin
story like they have the [__] you
know what I'm talking about like they
have the [__] like yeah you get a
[__] reason made it from the bottom
yeah like you get a [__] when you
wake up you have a reason in you yeah
yeah yeah that's one thing I always was
like real envious of you always wanted
that like coming from the mud coming out
the gutter yeah cause I was in there I
was in the [__] gutter but I didn't
nobody respects you because they like
yeah no right come on right yeah you're
the wrong color in the gutter yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah even though he could be
but it's like dog nah [__] out of there
yeah cause I I always I always really
really I think yeah that's why I mean I
think it's
I don't know it's like yeah we're not
you know I used to like be in like a
little like you know I used to hang with
the black guys and being like a little
gang it was like a shitty gang but oh
wait what was the name of y'all gang I
was in the Gang Too NFL it was called
NFL
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one